and just as the government stood behind
the british people through the pandemic
so we will help people deal with one of
the biggest costs they now face
energy
the energy regulator ofgem
announced this morning that the energy
price cap will rise in april to
1971 pounds
an increase of
693 pounds for the average household
without government action
this would be incredibly tough for
millions of hard-working families
so the government is going to step in to
directly help people manage those extra
costs
mr speaker before i set out the steps we
are taking
let me explain what is happening to
energy prices and why
people's energy bills are rising because
it is more expensive for companies who
supply our energy to buy oil coal and
gas
of the 693 pound increase in the april
price cap
around 80 percent comes from wholesale
energy prices
over the last year the price of gas
alone has quadrupled
and because over 85 percent of homes in
britain are heated with a gas boiler
and around 40 of our electricity comes
from gas
this is hitting households hard
now the reason gas prices are soaring
are global
across europe and asia a long cold
winter last year depleted gas stores
disruption to other energy sources like
nuclear and wind left us relying more
than usual on gas during the summer
months
surging demand in the world's
manufacturing centers in asia at the
same time as countries like china are
moving away from coal is further
increasing demand for gas
and concerns about a possible russian
incursion into ukraine are putting
further pressure on wholesale gas
markets
and so
prices are rising
mr speaker the price cap has meant that
the impact of soaring gas prices
has so far fallen predominantly on
energy companies
so much so
that some suppliers who couldn't afford
to meet those extra costs have gone out
of business as a result
it is not sustainable to keep holding
the price of energy artificially low
for me to stand here and pretend we
don't have to adjust to paying higher
prices
would be wrong and dishonest
but what we can do
is take the sting out of a significant
price shock for millions of families by
making sure the increase in prices
is smaller initially and spread over a
longer period
mr speaker without government
intervention the increase in the price
cap
would leave the average household having
to find an extra
693 pounds
the actions i'm announcing today
will provide to the vast majority of
households just over half of that amount
350 pounds
in total the government is going to help
around 28 million households this year
taken together this is a plan to help
with the cost of living worth around
nine billion pounds
we are delivering that support in three
different ways
first we will spread the worst of the
extra costs of this year's energy price
shock over time
this year all domestic electricity
customers will receive an upfront
discount on their bills worth 200 pounds
energy suppliers will apply the discount
on people's bills from october with the
government meeting the cost in full
that discount will automatically be
repaid from people's bills in equal
forty pound installments over the next
five years
this is the right way to support people
while staying on track with our plans to
repair the public finances
and because we are taking a fiscally
responsible approach
we can also provide more help faster to
those who need it most the second part
of our plan
we're going to give people a
150 pound council tax rebate to help
with the cost of energy in april and
this discount won't need to be repaid
and i do want to be clear with the house
that we are deliberately not just giving
support to people on benefits
lots of people on middle incomes are
struggling right now too
[Music]
so we have decided to provide the
council tax rebate to households in
bands a to d
this means around 80 percent of all
homes in england will benefit
and the third part of our plan will
provide local authorities with a
discretionary fund of nearly 150 million
pounds to help those lower income
households who happen to live in higher
council tax properties and households in
bands a to d who are exempt from council
tax at all
we're also confirming today that we'll
go ahead with existing plans to expand
eligibility for the warm homes discount
by almost a third so that three million
vulnerable households will now benefit
from that scheme
and that's not all we're doing to help
vulnerable households
we're providing three billion pounds
over this parliament to help more than
half a million lower income homes become
more energy efficient saving them on
average 290 pounds a year
increasing the national living wage to
nine pounds fifty an hour in april a
rise of over one 000 pounds for 2
million low-paid workers and we're
providing an effective tax cut for those
on universal credit allowing almost 2
million households to keep an average of
a thousand pounds per year
the payment through energy suppliers
will apply across england wales and
scotland energy policy has devolved in
northern ireland with a different
regulator and the government does not
have the legal powers to intervene but
we will make sure the executive is
funded to do something similar with
around 150 million pounds for northern
ireland through the barnet formula next
year
and because the council tax system is
england only total bonnet consequentials
of around 565 million pounds would be
provided to the devolved administrations
in the usual way
mr speaker i know that some in this
house have argued for a va t cut on
energy
however that policy
would disproportionately benefit
wealthier households
there would be no guarantee that
suppliers would pass on the discounts to
all customers
and we should be honest with ourselves
this would become a permanent government
subsidy on everyone's bills a permanent
subsidy worth two and a half billion
pounds every year at a time when we are
trying to rebuild the public finances
instead our plan
allows us to provide more generous
support
faster to those who need it most
providing 28 million households with at
least 200 pounds and the vast majority
receiving
350 pounds it is fair it is targeted it
is proportionate it is the right way to
help people with a spike in energy costs
mr speaker today's announcements are
just one part of the government's plan
to tackle this country's most pressing
economic challenges
a plan for growth with record investment
in infrastructure innovation and skills
a plan to restore the public finances
with debt falling by the end of this
parliament a plan to cut waiting lists
and back the nhs with 29 billion pounds
over three years and a permanent new
source of funding and with the measures
i've announced today a plan to help with
the rising cost of energy with 350
pounds more in the pockets of tens of
millions of hard-working families that's
our plan to build a stronger economy not
just today but for the long term